[Música]
la crisis energética sigue golpeando el
bolsillo de los ciudadanos alemanes esto
es economía en directo américa edición
nocturna hasta conmigo en el estudio
jorge hurtado jorge buenas noches que
hacen los alemanes entonces bueno ahora
los alemanes se enfrentan a un nuevo
impuesto sobre el gas natural que
consume en el cual es utilizado para
calentar a miles de hogares
principalmente en invierno y generar
electricidad la asociación de operadores
de gasoducto alemana fijó el impuesto de
24 centavos de euro por kilowatio hora
luego de que el parlamento aprobara una
legislación en la que tenía un rango
esperado de 5 centavos la medida fue
tomada para ayudar a importadores de gas
afectados por estos constantes recortes
rusos vinculados a la guerra en ucrania
según la agencia reuters en con este
nuevo impuesto que empieza a regir a
partir del primero de octubre una
familia de cuatro miembros en alemania
tendría un incremento adicional en el
costo del gas de al menos 480 euros al
año mientras que las familias que
consumen hasta 20 mil kilovatios por
hora incurrirían en gastos adicionales
de casi 600 euros anuales escuchemos y
que decía y el ministro alemán de
economía
este gravamen es la forma más justa
posible de distribuir y soportar los
costos adicionales que se han acumulado
entre la población la alternativa no es
la falta de gravamen la alternativa
habría sido el colapso del mercado
energético alemán y con él gran parte
del mercado energético europeo banca ni
mixta mente de canatra hosting y lo
hemos reportado aquí varias veces jorge
los bancos centrales incrementando las
tasas de interés para mejorar la
situación pero china hace todo lo
contrario la apuesta entonces al consumo
siempre digo que ver a china es como ver
un poco el futuro inicio los primeros
recortes de tipos de interés desde enero
ubicando la nueva tasa en unos mínimos
históricos según el emisor la rebaja de
diez puntos básicos de los servicios de
préstamos está orientada principalmente
a mantener una liquidez razonable y
suficiente en el sistema bancario
varios analistas económicos del país
asiático aseguran que la medida llega
luego de temores de deuda una mayor
presión por la devaluación del yuan y el
aumento de la inflación tras las medidas
restrictivas que intentaban contener
estos contagioso estos confinamientos
por la variante omicron de kobe 19 una
decisión que la segunda economía más
grande del mundo toma en dirección
opuesta a la que el resto de bancos
centrales del mundo está tomando los
últimos meses pues con el recorte en sus
tasas ahora esperan que la población
acceda a más créditos para comprar más y
que la actividad económica aumente vamos
a cómo les funciona el experimento lo
decíamos al inicio del programa kenia
tiene el nuevo presidente y este
mandatario tendrá que hacer frente a la
desigualdad que se registra en este país
una realidad similar de muchos países
africanos y está precisamente es una
noticia de esa desigualdad kenia con una
población de 50 millones de personas y
con un producto interno bruto compuesto
mayoritariamente por servicios y
agricultura es uno de los países más
desiguales del continente en nairobi la
capital los ciudadanos de los barrios
marginales empezaron a usar las bolsas
de plástico como combustible común ya
que no pueden acceder a combustibles
como el carbón vegetal y el gas debido
al alto costo de estos aunque expertos
han advertido que la quema de estas
bolsas son perjudiciales para el medio
ambiente y sobre todo para la salud
humana muchos kenianos aseguran que ni
siquiera tienen opción de comprar leña
fina para cocinar sus propios alimentos
y pasamos ahora a hablar de brasil allí
parece que la economía empieza a marchar
mejor brasil acumuló un alza del 2,24
por ciento los últimos primeros seis
meses de este año según el banco central
de ese país luego de haber sufrido las
consecuencias de la pandemia en el mismo
período del año pasado la principal
economía de latinoamérica pasa por una
fase de recuperación a un ritmo de
crecimiento interanual del 2,18 por
ciento según los últimos datos el
gobierno brasileño asegura que espera
una expansión del producto interno bruto
del 2% para este año mientras el fondo
monetario internacional estima una
expansión de tres puntos porcentuales
menos del 17 aproximadamente aunque todo
esto se muestra como datos optimistas el
país todavía debe afrontar una elevada
inflación que en los últimos 12 meses
acumula el 10,07 por ciento y nueva
batalla entre tweeter versus y los
moscos que pasó luego de que los tratará
de cancelar el acuerdo de compra con
twitter en repetidas ocasiones el hombre
más rico del mundo acusó a la red social
de ocultar los nombres de los
trabajadores que son responsables de
evaluar cuánto de la base de clientes de
la plataforma está compuesta por spam y
cuentas de robots que pidió a la
compañía proporcionar todos y cada uno
de estos datos de sus empleados sin
embargo este lunes la jueza de la corte
de cancillería de delaware donde se
realizaría este juicio aseguró que
twitter no tiene que entregar a los
mossos estos documentos muchas gracias
jorge por esta actualización del mundo
de la economía hasta aquí punto final en
este bloque informativo en directo
américa a continuación el debate